par qui vous avez été alerté on a été
alerté par le Commissariat d'Argenteuil
d'accord qui vous a dit quoi qui nous a
dit qu'ils avaient un signalement avec
un chiot maltraité d'accord arrivé sur
place donc vous découvrez le chien dans
quel état le chien est en très mauvais
état on découvre des brûlures des
fractures de nombreux hématomes voilà
comme on peut voir sur la photo il a la
tête complètement déformée il a beaucoup
de mal à se déplacer
même pas à marcher
pas du tout genre
de très nombreuses fractures
c'est quoi des brûlures qui ont été
infligés à l'animal oui soit avec des
cigarettes ou soit avec de l'acide
d'accord vous avez
pu regarder où est-ce que c'était
c'était si on avait énormément il y
avait beaucoup alors ils sont présents
surtout le corps bien évidemment dès la
prise en charge nous avons emmené
l'animal chez un vétérinaire et
voilà on a le compte rendu du
vétérinaire il y a quand même
[Musique]
chien femelle d'environ 4 mois voilà plé
oreille gauche avec au thé matom associé
et oreilles très sale très mauvais état
général maigre il était il avait été pas
nourri
il avait aussi des problèmes de
déshydratation aussi
très grand nombre de cicatrices sur le
crâne le corps et les pâtes plie joue
droite circulaire pouvant être des
traces de brûlures de cigarette
plaie entre les yeux
et ma tombe de 10 cm de diamètre sur le
haut du crâne
œdème des deux joues ils ont fait des
radiographies écoutez bien
puissions de fracture du genou gauche
il avait une ancienne fracture de la
patte avant gauche avec formation
d'un problème au courant c'est ça
fracture du doigt 3 et 4 de la pâte
avant droite fracture des deux
mandibules suspicion d'une fracture du
crâne en retard de l'hématome à confirmé
par un scanner
fracture de la
hanche gauche
fracture ancienne des côtes 8 9 et 17
formations d'un autre problème aussi
ça c'était dans une anciennes blessures
en plus un 8 9 et 10 c'est-à-dire qu'il
avait déjà été massacré voilà les
lésions observées ce jour mettent en
évidence des sévices graves en vue de
son état de santé le placement famille
d'accueil est fortement recommandé bien
entendu
des coups qui n'ont pas été partis
portant une seule fois donc en plusieurs
épisodes apparemment
vous allez avoir la version dans un
instant j'ai le tu as d'autres infos sur
le chien d'abord oui j'ai une question à
vous poser est-ce que c'est vrai que le
vétérinaire a été tellement
halluciné par la douleur du chien qui
l'a placé sous morphine pour que ses
souffrances soient moins fortes oui tout
à fait dès l'arrivée de l'animal il a
été tout de suite passé sous morphine
pour alléger ses couleurs bien
évidemment j'aimerais savoir comment
est-ce que vous avez été alerté de la
situation du chien à quel moment vous
vous avez eu le l'info on a été contacté
directement par les forces de l'ordre
du chien sont en danger d'abord avant
qu'on revienne sur l'affaire alors non
heureusement mais elle risque d'avoir
des séquelles la vie bien sûr quel genre
de c'est Cali risque d'avoir des
traumatismes comment dire ça peut être
des traumatismes
des boiteries
aujourd'hui on va voir la version dans
un instant d'autres éléments parce que
vous avez toute la Virgin et on va voir
si on n'iront pas je sais plus vous avez
porté plainte contre les propriétaires
du chien
on a déposé plainte
d'accord vous avez dit quoi dans votre
plan
nous avons relaté l'effet voilà
le constat du vétérinaire oui nous nous
le dit de toute façon
des radios et ils voient l'antériorité
des blessures
des fractures qui commencent à être
consolidés donc
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
rencontré vous les propriétaires à un
moment ou pas du tout non vous les
connaissiez
c'est pas notre rôle nous c'est vraiment
la prise en charge de l'animal c'est ça
après une enquête de police
on dit on va on va vous raconter le
récit dans un instant
mais il risquerait jusqu'à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement oui parce que c'est 4
ans mais il peut y avoir des
circonstances aggravantes notamment si
on est propriétaire et puis en fonction
de votre plainte qui est pour acte de
cruauté mauvais traitement infligé sans
nécessité et privation de soins il peut
y avoir de multiples circonstances
aggravantes ça peut monter effectivement
à 4 ou 5 ans et 50000 euros d'amende
voilà ça c'est la peine maximale qui
pourrait être infligée aux propriétaires
du chien alors on va revenir sur les
propriétaires du chien est-ce que pour
vous déjà 5 ans est-ce que vous trouvez
que c'est c'est si c'était ce qu'il
faudrait pour moi c'est que ces peines
soient réellement infligées parce que là
on a vu vous vous souvenez de l'affaire
du rappeur qui qui a été condamné à des
jours amende entre guillemets là
maintenant je pense qu'il faudrait sévir
la loi existe les peines sont là il
faudrait qu'un jour elles soient
appliquées c'est de la maltraitance
animale c'est pour moi c'est exactement
comme de la maltraitance sur un homme
donc ça mérite sanction alors on va vous
raconter toute l'histoire une fois de
plus parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
tic-tocqueuse aussi un qui a signalé la
ferme
vendredi dernier donc les équipes de la
Fondation assistante aux animaux sont
contactés par la bague d'Argenteuil ce
que vous dites dans le Val-d'Oise
hébété par l'image que nous renvoie
cette petite boule recroquevillée nous
découvrons un petit être en très mauvais
état général maigre les et malnutri
boiseux par des par des pâtes fracassées
un corps parsemé de plaie et des
cicatrices de cigarettes et d'acide
celle qui a révélé la faire c'est une
tiktokieuse qui s'appelle betka qui a
publié plusieurs vidéos dans laquelle
elle explique l'histoire et assure avoir
tout fait pour récupérer l'animal
regardez en gros votre French McQueen
son chien son chiot et c'est son mec et
elle elle fait rien il le frappait
à la ceinture lui mettez des coups de
béquilles
ouais il le sortait jamais [ __ ] il
faisait bonne figure câlin tout ça mais
[ __ ] c'est du faux comment tu peux
créer un Instagram à ton chien alors que
tu le maltraites et le mettre dans des
clips alors que dans la vie de tous les
jours le chien il va mourir c'est je
serai pas intervenu serait mort il
serait mort
oui donc c'est cette tik tokyoogie alors
elle parle de rock et Roca donc qui
habite à Argenteuil depuis le mois de
juillet qui ont eu le chien au mois
d'octobre ils ont acheté à des éleveurs
600 euros il aura appelé Texas il avait
donc deux mois
apparemment l'éleveur les a prévenu qui
ne pouvait pas détenir le chien sans
avoir de permis c'est ça mais
l'info l'aura été donné après la chasse
et ce qu'ils disent absolument ils ont
eu le chien et je vais vous quand vous
voulez je vais vous donner leur version
qui s'est passé et eux estiment
effectivement comme les a pas prévenus
avant des règlements je précise
simplement que maintenant et en France
les règlements il suffit de regarder
quand on achète un chien il suffit de
lire le nom du chien et on a le
règlement mais eux dis ça voilà qu'ils
ont cherché un vétérinaire qui
accepterait de faire les papiers du
chien sans permis c'est ça
vous avez donné leur version dans un
instant le chien avait été utilisé
également dans un clip oui regardez
dans chaque business par chantier
c'est comme ça
toujours impeccable faire mieux que moi
le faire impeccable
que du budget sinon on sort pas
tout alors je précise quelque chose sur
les images que vous venez diffusé sur le
clip que que des gens spécialistes des
animaux m'ont décrypté vous avez parlé
au moment de la maltraitance du regard
du chien vous avez dit que le chien
avait des yeux qui exprimait la plus
grande douleur le désespoir et des gens
m'ont dit que déjà dans le clip
diffusé sur Youtube on voit les yeux du
chien qui expriment une souffrance
est-ce que ça votre avis c'est vrai
est-ce qu'au moment du clip déjà c'est
presque de la maltraitance de l'exhiber
comme ça c'est pas un objet vous pouvez
voir déjà la pommette du chien qui est
enflé on voit déjà que tu as reçu des
premier coup alors regardez on a une
compile du chien et ce que vous dites
une je pense que vous allez me dire la
même chose regarde je donnais à manger
pendant que eux ils dormaient qu'ils
étaient en haut parce que sinon j'allais
me faire cramer donner de l'eau je lui
ai donné mon manteau aussi la nuit pour
qu'elle dorme et d'ailleurs dès le matin
il lui enlever la le manteau de force et
la piétiner deux fois de suite alors
voilà la petite Texas le jour où rap et
Roca l'ont acheté donc du coup à partir
d'une semaine elle était déjà cabossée
donc vous pouvez le voir que elle a des
grosses bosses au niveau de la du visage
déjà alors qu'elle était à peine âgée de
une semaine et ensuite un mois plus tard
voilà Texas dans l'état où elle est
non mais c'est révoltant c'est un chien
martyr quoi
c'est à dire qu'effectivement le drame
survenu là c'est à dire c'est blessures
incroyables auraient pu être précédé
d'autres actes du côté éventuellement
c'est ce que vous dites vous dites qui
nous a si nous transperce le cœur et les
entrailles ce sont ses yeux implorants
de souffrance qui se posent sur nous
avec sa tête déformée par un hématome en
haut de son crâne et ses joues bosselait
qu'il a dit figure ont-ils utiliser
leurs points humains leurs pieds ou une
arme pour la mutiler comme cela cette
petite chaîne non identifiée et
rebaptisée par ses sauveteurs et
appartenant donc au coupe d'influenceurs
Europe et Roca French rap Queen déjà des
fables probablement connus des services
de police est exhibé mise en scène déjà
abîmée dans leur clip sur Youtube c'est
le clip
ils étaient connus ce qui devait venir
là aujourd'hui finalement ils viennent
pas ils viennent pas
non mais ils ont une version eux ils ont
une version
c'était connu parce qu'il y avait eu des
enquêtes qui à ma connaissance n'ont pas
eu de suite judiciaire je précise à ma
connaissance concernant des affaires de
notamment d'agression sexuelle voilà
c'est un couple très sulfureux ça c'est
objectif qui se met en scène s'exhibe
sur des sites pornographiques voilà ça
c'est pas répréhensible mais voilà ce
sont des gens sulfureux Cyril voilà ce
qu'on peut dire c'est un couple qui
n'est pas un couple comme tout le monde
c'est un couple qui parfois se met en
scène dans des états qui semblent à tout
le monde hors de la norme voilà alors il
y a pas mal de gens qui disent 5 ans
d'emprisonnement mais ça n'arrivera
jamais sur les animaux ça ne cette ça
n'est jamais arrivé jamais regardé timal
qui avait reconnu qui avait plaidé
coupable rappeur et qui était condamné à
6000 euros d'amende à des jours amende
en quelque sorte donc après on en avait
discuté ici alors qu'il risquait
beaucoup plus effectivement pour le
moment les lois sont là mais elles ne
sont pas appliquées à cessément c'est du
moins la vie quasi générale et encore
quelques temps c'était juste des amendes
là passer sur un truc pénal il y a pas
longtemps que tu peux avoir des peines
de prison mais encore quelques temps tu
pouvais taper un animal tu avec eux une
amende parce que c'est là c'est ça que
je veux dire ce que je veux dire c'est
ce que je veux dire c'est que si tu
donnes 5000 balles 6000 balles d'amende
ils ont encore plus de buzz en faisant
ça et encore plus de pubs dans ça ils
ont une chaîne Youtube apparemment c'est
plus courageux de taper un chien que de
venir ici pourquoi ils sont pas venus là
par contre ils ont plus de facilité à
taper un chien qui va venir là moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on que ça servent
d'exemple rien qu'on prenne un exemple
et qu'on ferme la chaîne Youtube donc je
vais vous donner je vais vous dire ce
qu'on a euh pour Rock et Roca l'état
dans lequel a été retrouvé le chien n'a
rien à voir avec eux ils disent que ils
sont toujours très bien occupés
concernant les traces d'acide et de
cigarettes et les coups avec une
matraque télescopique dont on parlait il
nie complètement l'effet assure que les
policiers n'ont rien trouvé pendant leur
perquisition
concernant la bosse sur la tête du chien
Texas la chienne voilà qui s'appelle hop
maintenant je serais tombé dans les
escaliers du loft et ce serait la raison
pour laquelle Texas avait une bosse sur
la tête et sans les papiers il ne
pouvait pas l'amener chez le vétérinaire
avait vétérinaire leur a conseillé
d'acheter une crème d'arnica et de
traiter le chien pendant une semaine une
semaine après
REP est Texas aurait chuté tous les deux
cette fois mais dans les et encore
pareil dans les escaliers apparemment
c'est une patinoire
parce que comment il se serait justifié
sinon ils auraient été de plain-pied ça
aurait été plus dur ils disent qu'ils ne
l'ont jamais tapé je dis ce qu'il dit
donc jamais tapé concernant les eaux
brisés ils auraient remarqué que le
chien boitait que quelques heures
seulement avant l'arrivée d'une personne
à leur domicile avant c'était après donc
apparemment donc c'est un complot contre
eux
qui clope
je vous dis
pour l'ennuire alors un complot pour
leur nuire c'est ça alors dites nous
racontez-nous l'histoire alors eux
effectivement par rapport à
l'antériorité parce qu'entre guillemets
ils sont ils sont malins ils voient bien
qu'il y a des blessures anciennes donc
leur justification c'est tout ce qui a
lu Cyril des chutes etc sur l'effet là
très grave pour eux c'est un complot
contre mener pardon qu'une influenceuse
qui a révélé l'affaire qui leur en veut
ce sont des rivalités entre
influenceuses elle aurait profité d'une
soirée chez eux pour massacrer le chien
c'est leur terme et leur faire porter le
chapeau voilà leur version que je donne
à plat ce qui paraît très étonnant
effectivement mais il fallait donner
leur version
alors après cet épisode ils disent
qu'ils ont décidé de payer un dog sitter
pour s'occuper du chien lorsqu'ils
étaient absents
voilà et
cette tiktokeuse donc affirme que le
précédent chien d'Europe Hero castrémor
après avoir été trempé dans de l'acide
et qu'ils auraient l'habitude de tuer
des animaux
aujourd'hui rrop et Roca disent qu'ils
sont très tristes de ne plus voir leur
chien et se disent victime d'une grande
injustice
quelles coûts ont reçu eux quoi
la version qui donne et quand même alors
ils sont pas là mais moi j'ai donné leur
version mais ça paraît très étonnant par
rapport à l'ampleur des blessures et la
souffrance du chien c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a un décalage total il y a aucun aveu
aucun regret c'est pas nous du tout
Cyril sur la alors le chien n'a que 4
mois mais ça paraît surréaliste par
rapport à tout ce qu'on voit tout ce
qu'on entend qui a eu qu'il n'y ait eu
de leur part aucun acte répréhensible
commis contre le chien alors pour eux
donc je vous dis ce serait la Tic-Toc
qui pour leur nuire est-ce qu'on a
enquêter là-dessus alors on a pour le
moment uniquement
l'antériorité des coûts signalés par le
vétérinaire pour moi Cyril ça c'est la
base il y a eu la plainte donc il y aura
une enquête
la base c'est que du coup sont répétés
donc ça peut pas être là l'influenceuse
qui est venu chez eux avant et juste
surréaliste à tout le monde moi j'ai
discuté avec les gens des services de
protection animale aujourd'hui ils me
disent mais des chutes ne font pas ça
c'est impossible donc voilà aujourd'hui
ça paraît impossible oui ils disent que
rope donc c'est rope et Roca c'est hop
c'est le c'est le monsieur c'est ça va
les photos s'il vous plaît ce serait de
Monsieur il est atteint d'une maladie
orpheline lamilose qui entraîne des
pertes de force soudaine et donc c'est
il dirait que c'est pour ça que quand il
serait dans les escaliers il aurait
lâché le chien ou voilà il serait tombé
avec lui tu en as entendu parler de ça
non j'avais pas entendu parler de ça
j'avais pas jusque-là voilà donc c'est
ça serait la la la j'ai entendu parler à
leur sujet de cette maladie orpheline
non plus hein voilà je me tiens mais
c'est pas mal il tombe avec le chien en
même temps
c'est dramatique il faut savoir que
c'est notre combat du quotidien
malheureusement voilà c'est et il faut
savoir que depuis quelques temps il y a
une hausse de la cruauté animale voilà
30% c'est énorme
sans permis sans permis le risque de 3
mois de ton prisonnement une amende de
3750 € et le retrait du chien le retrait
du chien déjà
il est considéré ce chien comme un chien
de catégorie 2 il faut un permis de
détention de chiens d'y susceptibles
d'être dangereux c'est ça mais le
staffie LOF lui en est exemples
absolument et je tiens quand même à
préciser qu'à ma connaissance peut-être
que vous allez me démentir mais quand
vous avez un chien qui se blesse un
chien qui subit une chute qui a une
blessure grave même si vous n'avez pas
de papier c'est un peu comme les
médecins soit il y a des vétérinaires
qui dans une situation d'urgence peuvent
soigner un chien est-ce que vous me
confirmez ça oui tout à fait
bien sûr par exemple je sais que à
l'école vétérinaire Maisons-Alfort on
dépose des animaux vous me confirmez ils
sont soignés donc j'ai vu avec eux ils
m'ont dit que si on leur amène un chien
même sans papiers grièvement blessé sera
pris devant pas laisser ce chien sans
soin alors donc leur test Cyril là de
dire nous n'avions pas de papier nous
n'avons vous savez vous avez lu ça nous
n'avons pas osé l'amener chez le
vétérinaire
non non mais je veux dire elle
s'effondre ces tests s'effondre
d'elle-même Cyril alors Gilles juste une
petite dernière chose
aujourd'hui ils sont ils devaient venir
ici donc pour l'instant ils sont pas
est-ce qu'ils sont poursuivis non il y a
une plainte qui est déposé d'accord mais
pour le moment non il y a pas encore de
mise en examen reste à savoir s'il va y
avoir une instruction ou si comme le
rappeur ils vont finir par se raviser
peut-être sur les conseils d'un avocat
et plaider coupable c'est ce qu'a fait
le rappeur il avait plaidé coupable
c'est la fameuse procédure qui vous
permet d'être jugé pour un délit assez
immédiatement pour le moment s'il
continue à nier il peut très bien y
avoir ouverture d'une information
de la part des policiers une enquête
pour effectivement il y a une
perquisition déjà pour savoir s'il y a
enériorité des coûts si ces gens-là ont
déjà tapé des chiens voilà et à fortiori
pareil on découvre que ils sont accusés
d'être responsables de la mort d'un
autre animal je sais pas si vous aviez
des informations là-dessus mais là vous
en aviez non déjà alors
on regarde les réseaux sociaux comme
tout le monde voilà comment on s'informe
nous après notre travail c'est vraiment
de s'occuper des animaux et la prise en
charge de l'animal après la police et la
justice se chargera
vous confirmez qu'il y avait déjà eu des
sévices sur un autre animal
c'est ce qui se lit dans les réseaux
sociaux
apparemment il y aura une antériorité de
la violence contre amener le chien c'est
ça alors je ne savais pas qu'ils avaient
tué le chien mais il y aura eu la perte
d'un animal effectivement il a déposé
plein de contrôle
l'association
merci à vous aussi merci d'avoir été
continué ce que vous faites bravo bravo
les chéris